we thought the Michelle might win and we
knew that you were coming with her so we
got you again like you think we don't
already have one this is the one this is
the one that I mean really really so
much always remember tonight good luck
on tangling with our best friend leather
jacket yes best friend thing going yeah
that speech said so much
that speech was something and what did
it mean they win but get up on that
stage and think about others it was if
I'm being honest if there's you know
when you're sitting there you're like
you know win or lose like it doesn't it
doesn't really change anything and it
happens it doesn't happen like I'm not
in control of that I don't mind the part
of me that wanted to win was just
because I really wanted to be able to
talk about pay equality and not about
what it's like for me because I have it
so much better than so many I really
wanted to be able to talk about what it
was like for most women and so that it's
been like the great privilege of my
lifetime to sort of find myself as the
spokesperson for pay inequity the two of
us girls making good form dawson's great
well I was gonna say James is here have
you seen him dance yet okay I have to
say something this Michelle doesn't she
doesn't she is truly a person that
doesn't like have a television like you
know how people say that and you're like
yeah you do we get it working tonight so
that my daughter could watch this I mean
she truly doesn't but of course I've
seen James dance and he's killing it and
I want him to win any love you want to
send him send him a message we'll see
him at a rehearsal
well James you I want you to win he's
are you wait to see this yeah new you
have to see he's on Dancing with the
Stars No
okay as you were listening that speech
you were overcome by emotion and what
was going through your head busy while
you're listening to Michelle I'm so
incredibly proud of her for her own
personal accomplishments and work
accomplishments but also that you know
she's really choosing chosen at this
moment to use her voice for others and I
just love her so much and she deserves
everything and I was happy to see it
vasee Burton was amazing but there was
so much we didn't know about that
relationship and how much there was a
contribution that wasn't from Fosse that
surprised us all what did it mean to
play a woman who's been marginalized by
time so many women have come up to me
and they said I am Gwen like I'm Gwen in
my relationship like I'm the unsung hero
so I'm happy to see that people can
recognize themselves in her and I'm also
happy to see that Gwen herself is sort
of getting her due and people are
looking back through her work to see who
she was and what her contributions were
and how she really was the greatest
dancer of her time and maybe this time
she was touched by God
[Music]